Simplifica
"4a" cuadrada "b"
y todo eso elevado al cubo.
En este caso vamos a usar la propiedad que nos dice que si tienes "a" por "b"
elevado a la "n",
esto es igual a "a" a la "n"
por "b" a la "n",
y para darnos cuenta
porque se cumple esto,
hagamos un ejemplo simple.
Si tenemos "a" por "b"
a la tercera potencia
¿A qué va a ser igual esto?
Esto va a ser igual a
"a" por "b", ahí está la primera potencia, por "a" por "b", ahí estaría la segunda potencia
por "a" por "b",
ahí estaría a la tercera potencia.
Básicamente estamos tomando esta expresión
y la estamos multiplicando por sí misma 3 veces.
Ahora, estos términos podemos intercalarlos
usando la propiedad conmutativa
y asociativa de la multiplicación.
Así es que intercambiando estos, intercambiando el orden en el que se están multiplicando,
esto lo podemos escribir como
"a", por "a", por "a",
por "b", por "b", por "b".
Aquí tenemos 3 "a" y 3 "b",
así es que esto de aquí es "a" al cubo
y esto de aquí es "b" al cubo.
Tenemos "a" al cubo por "b" al cubo,
funcionó la propiedad
y espero que hayas podido ver porqué
esta propiedad funciona.
Apliquémosla al problema que tenemos,
tenemos "4a" cuadrada "b"
y eso elevado al cubo.
Lo que significa que cada uno de los elementos de este producto se van a elevar al cubo.
Esto va a ser igual a 4 elevado al cubo
por "a" cuadrada elevado al cubo,
por "b" elevado al cubo...
déjame usar aquí el color para codificar esto...
aquí tenemos este cubo estamos elevando 4 al cubo,
"a" cuadrada  lo estamos elevando al cubo,
y "b" lo estamos elevando al cubo,
en vez de hacer el producto primero
y luego elevar al cubo,
estamos elevando al cubo primero
y posteriormente vamos a hacer el producto.
Eso es lo que estamos haciendo,
vamos a simplificar esto,
¿Cuánto es 4 al cubo?
4 al cubo es 4 a la 1 es 4
4 al cuadrado es 16,
4 al cubo es 16 por 4
16 por 4 es 64,
y luego tenemos,
"a" al cuadrado y eso elevado al cubo,
y sabemos por la regla del producto de los exponentes,
que eso va a ser igual a "a" elevado a la 2 por 3,
ó "a" elevado a la sexta...
"a" a la sexta,
el 6 sale de 2 por 3...
y finalmente
tenemos "b" cúbica.
Voy a hacerlo con un color distinto,
tenemos la "b" cúbica
y hemos simplificado la expresión a
64 "a" a la sexta "b" cúbica.